what was the thing you were up for when
they wanted to do the really crate the
we used some sort of drug because I'm a
that was a nightmare but I've kind of
horrible woman other many auditions that
I've had to get myself out of because it
was it was just bad bad bad bad when you
were young actors they just make you do
stuff that you know there was one
particularly my agent once picked me up
for something which which she was
convinced was it was gonna be something
great for me I had to learn songs I had
to play the guitar and all that kind of
stuff I said no problem and of course
the day came and I just haven't probably
shut all that so I didn't have it and I
stood in front of them and my heart was
in my mouth
and I just thought I've gotta get out of
this so I started to cry and I said and
I said and they'll probably if they ever
hear the stuff sank wow we really
believed him he's an absolute bastard
and I said to make myself crying I mean
I'm really sorry I'm really sorry I've
just had a phone call from uh me he's
been knockdowns and a support and
I'm going anything I'm going I'm going
all right I'm gonna how would you want
me to play okay yeah sure I'm sorry
about that
so you should be you know what should
oh the sword of the Lord is filled with
blood here we go
not all the additions went that
brilliantly in the beginning
do you know the one I'm talking about
the